es la cuarta investigación preliminar
que la fiscalía de perú abre contra el
presidente pedro castillo esta vez por
presunto delito contra la administración
de justicia y encubrimiento personal
algo que el mandatario desestima
nosotros no tenemos tiempo para
entretenernos en otras cosas nosotros no
estamos acá para hacer un circo el país
nos ha puesto para trabajar por el perú
el martes el jefe de estado del país
inca destituyó por sorpresa mariano
gonzález ministro del interior durante
15 días horas después de su despido
acusó al mandatario de estar
comprometido con actos de corrupción y
obstruir la justicia esto porque según
gonzález su destitución se produjo luego
de autorizar el nombramiento de una
unidad policial especial destinada a
localizar y arrestar a los aliados del
presidente que estén bajo investigación
penal como el ex ministro de transportes
juan silva el ex secretario de palacio
bruno pacheco y un sobrino del
mandatario fray vascas lo que recibí
fue un reclamo natural
porque él es porque no estaba de acuerdo
con mi decisión
no es que me haya dicho el presiente en
algún momento no capturé a los prófugos
pero lo que me cuestionaba era la
decisión
de ir por ellos las otras tres
investigaciones que castillo tiene
abiertas son una por presuntos delitos
de organización criminal y tráfico de
influencias en torno a contrataciones y
visitas en el ministerio de transporte y
comunicaciones otra por supuestas
irregularidades en ascensos en miembros
de las fuerzas armadas y de la policía y
otra en relación al presunto plagio de
su tesis doctoral
asimismo ha sobrevivido a dos intentos
de destitución y algunos legisladores
piden un tercer juicio político por las
nuevas acusaciones